Bangkok capitale de la Thaïlande que de
temps à autre l'histoire appelle Siam et
deux nom ce n'est pas trop pour désigner
le lieu de rencontre de deux
civilisations qui se jug àose sans
cercle ou se repousse de ville en ville
et de quartier en quartier sans que l'on
puisse dire encore si la vieille culture
orientale toujours vivante ici réussira
à la longue à l'usure à imposer son
détachement et sa prudence narcooise à
la vie moderne qui l'assaille de toutes
parts ou si c'est au contraire la vie
moderne qui finira par envoyer la
vieille sagesse orientale au musée parmi
les armures de bronze et les masques aux
yeux de
jade pour le moment il faut bien dire
que la vie moderne va de succès en
succès
la coulée de béton avance les grands
hôtels se multiplient offrant à leur
clientèle de touristes et d'hommes
d'affaires l'air conditionné la cuisine
internationale et la piscine des
résidences de luxe on pourrait croire
que le passé a disparu erreur il est en
face de l'autre côté de la rue il attend
son heure dans l'antique palais des rois
de Siam que voici où l'on nentre qu'à la
condition de porter vestons et Cravat
pour les dames une robe descente est
exigée le pantalon et le short sont
défendus le passé reçoit et n'aime pas
le
négliger dans le périmètre de cette
sorte de cremmelin extrême oriental
s'élève le temple du Boudha d'émeraudde
l'un des plus beaux parmi les 2000
temples de
Thaïlande à l'entrée prière cette fois
dotter ses chaussures deux géants
bariolés montent leur garde éternelle
avec une grimace prodigieuse
indubitablement teinté d'ironie et qui
s'adresse peut-être on en est réduite
aux conjectur par-dessus le mur
d'enceinte au génie concurrent à l'œuvre
dans la ville
nouvelle je ne vous apprendrai rien en
vous disant que le Siam je veux dire la
Thaïlande est bouddhiste qu'il y a par
ailleurs 500 millions de bouddhistes en
Orient et quelquesuns à Paris et que le
bouddhisme fondé sur une science
spirituelle très fine l'abstention du
péché la de l'homone et la considération
du au prochain quel que soit le nombre
de ces pattes je veux dire qu'il soit
homme ou animal est tenu pour
l'expression la plus ancienne de la
nonvolence
religieuse si cette musique vous paraît
quelque peu primitive c'est parce
qu'elle procède d'instruments
réfractaires à la mélodie mais c'est
l'un des cas où l'ancien rejoint le
nouveau où l'ancestral rattrape
l'ultraoderne bien des compositeurs
d'aujourd'hui jou de la dissonance la
différence est que la symbolique des
musiques anciennes s'est perdue et que
celle des musiques nouvelles n'est pas
encore
trouvé la danse orientale est
certainement le spectacle le plus
ravissant du monde vous êtes trop fin
connaisseur pour commettre l'erreur de
croire qu'il suffit de se peindre le
visage de revêtir des costumes de soi de
se faire pousser les ongles et de
disposer d'un peu d'inspiration pour
danser ainsi en fait chacun des gestes
de ces jeunes filles a une signification
tantôt sacrée tantôt simplement poétique
la plupart du temps oublié la lenteur
apparente de leur mouvement ajoute une
difficulté supplémentaire à l'exercice
et rendrait toute faute d'exécution
irréédable c'est après des années
d'études et d'entraînement qu'elles sont
autorisé à donner au public l'exemple de
ce que peuvent ensemble la pudeur la
mesure et la
grâce une deuxè erreur à ne pas
commettre serait d'accuser ces deux
traîneurs de sabre de se mettre en
contradiction avec l'idéal de non
violence qui est celui de leur religion
il s'agit évidemment d'un jeu d'adresse
entre deux partenaires hautement
qualifiés qui connaissent leur
répertoire offensif et défensif sur le
bout du doigt et qui manipule soit dit
en passant de vrais sabres et non des
colichemars de de pérett avec lesquels
il réduiseent la violence à l'état
d'abstraction agréablement
chorégraphique il n'y aura pas de
convoie
funèbre ici non plus la boxe
thaïlandaise qui n'est pas sans rappeler
la savate de la belle époque est encore
une manière de balai moins subtile que
le précédent
toutefois le règlement est
succès il est défendu cracher d'enfoncer
son pouce dans l'œil de l'adversaire et
de mordre exceptter la
poussière on diserne une trace de
doctrine section réincarnation dans la
manière dont les adversaires se
présentent au public ceuxci se font
appeler en thaïlandais jeunes lions se
battant avec leur
points
quant au combat de coque distraction
populaire je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire
qu'il mettent au prise des coqus non
violents non mais enfin ces combats se
livrent sans les ergos de fer ou d'acier
qui rendent ailleurs ce spectacle
insupportable la plus grande partie de
la production thaïlandaise de bien de
consommation et d'origine artisanale la
moitié de la production nationale de
vêtements de coton est tissée à la main
par de jeunes et moins jeune
thaïlandaise comme dans tous les pays
neufs pour le touriste édifié sur un
passé imposant les industries du
souvenir de voyage sont nombreuses et
proposent dans tous les format
d'innombrables statuettes du Boudha des
objets en lac des vases de céladon
imités de l'art ancien les techniques
n'ont pas changé elles sont toujours
aussi
sûres
cet éléphant est taillé dans du bois de
teek car l'une des grandes industries
locales et l'exploitation des forêts de
teek des montagnes du Nord le te est un
bois magnifique très lourd très dur et
très difficile à transporter ancêtre du
bouldldozer l'éléphant du Siam est charg
soit porter soit pousser les énormes
Fues vers les rivières qui les mèneront
à la
Syrie
et ceci n'est pas un promeneur forestier
du dimanche qui lave sa voiture mais un
convoyeur expérimenté qui sait que les
éléphants peuvent travailler plus de 4
heures par jour qu'il craigne la chaleur
et qu'à la sortie du chantier rien ne
leur fait plus plaisir qu'une
douche
passé présent futur de quelle époque est
la sagesse
personnifié par les milliers de boudas
au sourire intérieur sur lesquels il
semble que le temps n'est pas de
prise c'est peut-être parce qu'elle a
été souvent représentée sous la forme du
serpent cette sagesse que l'Institut
d'ophiologie de Bangkok entretient avec
soin toutes les variété de reptiles que
le pays met à sa disposition ils sont
nourris une fois par semaine le
lundi le
jeudi les experts de l'Institut les
pressent énergiquement de livrer leur
venin dont la médecine tire un précieux
sérum ce sont des serpents de
laboratoire qui aident à guérir leurs
morsures
passé présent futur Orient
Occident ancienne résidence d'été des
rois si construite au 17e siècle dans un
style composite appartient à l'un et à
l'autre mais les tour
d'utia à 64 km au nord de Bangkok et Jad
capit appartiennent bien à l'Orient du
rêve avec leur formes
relevé navigantes et
pointu leur décoration minutieuse et
précise la superposition de leur toiture
et ces bonnets pareils à des index
effilés dorés par le soleil qui montrent
les
nuages
mais voici la fin du voyage ces canaux
qui achèvent de nous dépayser en nous
parlant de
Venise ce sont les rues de la Bangkok
d'autrefois les premières rues de pavé
et d'Asphalt ne datent que de
1860 dans la ville
ancienne la vie quotidienne se laisse
porter au fil de l'eau verte elle s'y
trempe elle s'y mire elle peut y
regarder son passé dédoublé qui
l'accompagne ou qui la
suit le canal ou l'autoroute l'Artis le
manager le yogi ou le commissaire le
recueillement ou la technique passé
présent futur à quel temps faut-il
conjuguer la
Thaïlande mais peut-être est-il de ces
rares pays où le futur ne se croit pas
tenu pour paraître d'abolir le
passé